let's say that I have some function s of
T which is position as a function of
time position as a function function of
time and let me graph a potential s of T
right over here we have a horizontal
axis as the time axis and let me just
graph something I'll drop kind of
parabola looking although I could have
done in general but just to make things
a little bit simpler for me so I'll draw
it kind of parabola looking so that is
if we call this a y-axis we could even
call this Y y equals s of T as a
reasonable as a reasonable way to graph
our position as a function of time
function and now let's think about what
happens if we were to if we want to
think about the change in position
between two x let's say between time a
let's say that's time a right over there
and then this right over here is time B
so time B is right over here so what
would be the change in position between
time a and between time B well at time B
at time B we are at s of B we are at s
of B position and at time a we are at s
of we were at s of a position s of a
position so the change in position
between time a and time B let me write
this down the change change in position
position between and this might be
obvious to you but I'll write it down
between x times a and B is going to be
equal to s of B this position this
position s of B minus this position
minus s of a minus s of a so nothing
earth-shattering so far but now let's
think about what happens if we take the
derivative of this function right over
here so what happens when we take the
derivative of a position as a function
of time so remember the derivative gives
us the slope of the tangent line at any
point so let's say we're looking at a
point right over there the slope of the
tangent line it tells us for a very
small
Ginty I'm exaggerating it visually for a
very very small change in T how much are
we changing in position how much are we
changing in position so we write that as
D s DT is the derivative of our position
function at any given time so when we're
talking about how the rate at which
position changes with respect to time
what is that well that is equal to
velocity so this is equal to velocity
well let me write this in different
notations so this itself is going to be
a function of time so we could write
this this is equal to s prime of T these
are just two different ways of writing
the derivative of s with respect to T
this makes it a little bit clearer that
this itself is a function of time and we
know that this is the exact same thing
as velocity velocity as function of time
as function of time which we will write
which will real write as V of T so let's
graph what V of T might look like down
here let's graph it so let me let me put
another axis another axis down here that
looks pretty close to the original give
myself some real estate so that looks
pretty good
and then let me try to graph a V of T so
once again if this is my y-axis this is
my t axis and I'm going to graph y is
equal to V of T and if this really is a
parabola then the slope over here is
zero the slope the rate of change is
zero and then it keeps increasing the
slope gets steeper and steeper and
steeper and so V of T might look
something like this V of T might look
something like this so this is the graph
of y is equal to V of T now using this
graph let's think if we can think of if
we can conceptualize the distance the or
the change in position between time a
and between time B and between time
II well let's go back to our Riemann
sums let's think about what an area of a
very small rectangle would represent so
let's divide this into a bunch of
rectangles so I'll try to I'll do it
fairly large rectangle so we have some
space to work with but you can imagine
much smaller ones and I'm going to do a
left Riemann sum here just because we've
done those a bunch but we could do a
right Riemann sum we could do a
trapezoidal sum we could do anything we
want so and then we could keep going all
the way actually let me just do let me
just do three right now let me just do
three right over here and so this is
actually a very rough approximation but
you can imagine it might get closer but
what is what is each the area of each of
these rectangles trying what is it an
approximation for well this one right
over here you have F of a or I should
say V of a so your velocity at time a is
the height right over here and then this
distance right over here is a change in
time times delta T so the area the area
for that rectangle is your velocity at
that moment times your change in time
what is the velocity at moment times
your change in time well that's going to
be your change in position so this will
tell you this is an approximation of
your change in position over this time
then this rectangle the area of this
rectangle is another approximation for
your change in position over the next
over the next Delta T and then you can
imagine this is right over here is an
approximation for your change in
position for the next delta T so if you
really wanted to figure out your change
in position between a and B you might
want to just do a Riemann sum if you
want it approximate it you would want to
take the sum from I equals 1 to I equals
n of V of and I'll do a left Riemann sum
but once again we could use the midpoint
we can do trapezoids we could do the
right Riemann sum but I'll just do a
left one because that's what I depicted
right here V of T V of T of I minus one
so if this is this would be T naught
would be a so this is the first this is
the first rectangle so the first
rectangle you use the function evaluated
at T naught for the second rectangle use
the function evaluated at T 1 we've done
this in mole
couple videos already and then we
multiply it times each of the changes in
time this will be an approximation this
will be an approximation for our total
for our total and let me make it clear
where where delta T is equal to B minus
a over the number of intervals we have
we already know from many many videos
when we looked at Riemann sums that this
will be an approximation well will be an
approximation for two things we just
talked about it'll be an approximation
for our change in position but it's also
an approximation for our area so this
right over here so we're trying to
approximate approximate change in
position change in position and this is
also approximate of the area under the
curve area under under the curve so
hopefully this satisfies you that if you
are able to calculate the area under the
curve and actually this one's pretty
easy because it's a trapezoid but even
if this was a function if it was kind of
a wacky function it would still apply
that when you're calculating the area
under the curve of the velocity function
you are actually figuring out the change
in position these are the two things
well we already know what could we do to
get a very to get the exact to get the
exact area under the curve or to get the
exact change in position well we just
have a ton of rectangles we take the
limit as the number of rectangles we
have approaches infinity we take the
limit as n approaches infinity and as n
approaches infinity because it's because
delta T is B minus a divided by and
delta T is going to become infinitely
small it's going to turn into DTS as one
way to think about it and we already
have notation for this this is the
riemann this is it one way to think
about a Riemann integral we just use the
left Riemann sum once again we could use
the right Riemann sum etc etc we could
have used a more general Riemann sum but
this one will work so this will be equal
to the definite integral from A to B of
V T V of T DT so this right over here is
one way of saying look if we want the
exact area under the curve of the
velocity curve which is going to be the
exact change in position between a and B
we can denote it this
it's the limit of this Riemann sum as n
approaches infinity or the definite
integral from A to B of V of T DT but
what did we just figure out so remember
this is another this is the we could
call this the exact the exact change in
position change in position between
between times a and B but we already
figured out what the exact change in
positions between times a and B are it's
this thing it's this thing right over
here and so this gets interesting we now
have a way of evaluating this definite
integral conceptually we knew that this
is the exact change in position between
a and B but we already figured out a way
to figure out the exact change of
position between a and B so let me write
all this down we have that the definite
integral between a and B V of T DT is
equal to is equal to s of B s of B minus
s of a minus s of a where where let me
write this in a new color where where s
of T is the we know V of T is the
derivative of s of T so we can say where
s of T is the anti anti derivative
derivative of V of T and this notion
although I've written in a very
non-traditional used I've used position
velocity this is the second fundamental
theorem of calculus fundamental theorem
and you're probably wondering about the
first we'll talk about that in another
video but this is a super useful way of
evaluating definite integrals and
finding the area of look under a curve
second fundamental theorem of calculus
very closely tied to the first
fundamental theorem which we won't talk
about now so why is this such a big deal
well let me write it in the more general
notation the way that you might be used
to seeing it in your calculus book it's
telling us that if we want the area
under the curve between two points a and
B between two X points a and B of f of X
and so this is how we would denote the
area under the curve between those two
intervals so let me draw
just to make it clear what I'm talking
about in general terms so this right
over here could be f of X and we care
about the area under the curve between a
and B if we want to find this exact area
under the curve we could we can figure
it out by taking the antiderivative of F
and let's just say that capital f of X
is the antiderivative anti derivative or
is an antiderivative because you can
have multiple that are shifted by
constant is an antiderivative is
antiderivative of F then you just have
to take evaluate the antiderivative at
the endpoints and take the difference so
you take the the endpoint first I guess
the you subtract the antiderivative
evaluated at the starting point from the
antiderivative evaluated at the endpoint
so you get capital F of B minus capital
F of a so if you want to figure out the
exact area of the curve you you you take
the antiderivative of it and evaluate
that at the endpoint at the endpoint and
from that you subtract the starting
point so hopefully that makes sense in
the next few videos we'll actually apply
it